You're already paying thousands of dollars for an attorney
for custody court.
A little hundred and something extra isn't what's breaking the bank.
The situation is what sucks.
The fact that you need this is what sucks.
But buying this is not what's breaking the bank,
and it's not, you know,
hurting anything. This,
if anything,
is gonna help you maximize the larger investment of the attorney,
of the college classes, of the courses that you're taking.
And actually, right now it's $30 off.
It's normally 1 85 and it's like 1 55 right now on the TikTok shop.
It's linked right here. It is truly worth it, like,
cause the way it lays out all the information for you is like,
it's just so much work done for you
and so much of the remembering,
you know what I mean? Like,
if I'm paying my attorney $500 an hour,
when I talk to him on the phone,
I want every last detail of what he said so that I'm not forgetting it.
Cause what's the point of paying for all this money if it's like, ah,
I'm too, I'm too chaotic to kind of do my part in the process?
So this is.
It's like you constantly have an assistant that's helping you,
someone walking into every meeting with you.
You know, you have your little AI virtual assistant on your phone
walking into every meeting,
attending every phone call with you.
And so, you know,
it just helps You maximize the bigger investment,
so. But okay.
It's linked right here. If you want one